i believe a three sport athlete in high
school football basketball and track
todd gurley joins us with a phillies hat
on
what are you doing with the phillies hat
on oh it matched my outfit i got a bart
simpson shirt
my question is y'all got any lamb chops
over there on that traeger grill
um we can we can make some
are you a great option are you a griller
yeah i love the grill all right now do
you have a go-to
probably lamb chop pork chop nice young
burgers
so everything let me let me see your
shirt
let me see your shirt can you uh tilt
down and
i don't know how i do it's like it's
like a little bart simpson shirt
oh okay so the only reason why you have
the hat on is it matches
bart simpson i like that i got i got
love for philly too the city of
brotherly love
so yeah but you grew up in maryland or
born in maryland grew up in north
carolina
yeah i gotta got the oreos tatted on me
but
sometimes they make me just so angry man
wait you have an orioles tattoo yeah
where is it it's like like my stomach
is that one of those tattoos you regret
they're making me regret it
but if they win the world series you're
going to be the first to say look at my
tattoo here oh most definitely
it's hard it's hard though with the
yankees the red sox
like you know trying to compete with
those guys as well yeah it's like trying
to compete with the patriots
yeah did you get any grief when you
wished tom brady
a happy birthday a couple of years ago
didn't you have an actual goat
in in uh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well
because we share the same birthday
and it's just like you know it's tom
brady birthday basically and then mine
is like second
so when they say famous people born on
this day
it's tom brady and then it gets to you
right after that
nah just tom brady and everybody else
i i noticed that uh you're selling your
house in los angeles right
yeah now you bought that from tyler
taylor lautner is that the the uh the
twilight guy
oh no no uh yeah i bought that house
from him but i'm selling my
my place that i was in when i was
playing in los angeles
okay so anybody want to buy a house you
know five bedroom six bath y'all let me
know
but did you meet taylor lautner when you
bought that oh you did
yeah yeah pretty cool dude
did he know who you were yeah
he's a saints fan though so you know how
that goes now
so he didn't give you a discount um
just a little bit just a little bit just
a little bit
so how weird is it that you know you're
trying
to get ready for that football season
it's four weeks
from last night yeah like what's your
day like
what is a normal day like at training
camp
i mean i keep telling people it's really
not training cameras
like training camp is when we used to
wake up and get
after the facility at 8 am and we was in
it
at 8 or 9. now it's like you know
virtual meetings in in the dorm rooms or
you know
at the house it was a lot easier than it
than it was
you know i'm not going to complain being
a vet in this league but
i mean really just come in the building
you know you do our meetings well right
now we're
starting practice um then right after
practice you get lunch recovery
and then we'll start meetings for about
two two to three hours and then after
that
we'll do the walkthrough and then our
day is pretty much over with
around about six o'clock so it could
always be worse that's why i'm not
complaining i've been through
the long days of training camp for two
three weeks how tough is it going to be
for the rookies though todd
yeah i feel like it's going to be a lot
tougher for them just as far as
getting the opportunity to make the team
but not only that
not only that you know when it's time to
play um
it's going to be very difficult but
that's when we got to do a good job of
getting those guys ready in practice
um every day you know showing them full
speed reps because
once things amp up it gets going pretty
fast so
just trying to trying to tell them you
know just control what you can control
it's a tough situation for everybody and
everybody kind of
got to be on the same page right now but
uh just keep inspiring them and just
giving them knowledge what is why the
falcons
it was just just the right fit for me
you know i feel like same style of
offense um
obviously you know they have a great
offense and then
you know coach coach john quinn he's
heard tremendous great things about him
i felt like you know this system um the
brotherhood
kind of fit me you know talking with
julio
obviously wanting to play with a great
receiver like that
um guys like ridley uh russ
and then you know we had a younger
running back room so it was time for me
to go in and
be able to share my knowledge as well
get those guys ready for
when i'm not here and those guys ready
for the future but
and then i mean i play here at georgia
man university of georgia bulldog
um yeah atlanta falcon can't really name
too many bulldogs that that went into
that so
how competitive was practice so you have
sony michelle nick chubb and you
at georgia damn yeah
it was it was it was great i feel like
our running back coach mcclendon on bmac
he he gave us
a lot of good you know words of
encouragement
a lot of good coaching but he showed us
how to practice
i know that's one thing about the nfl
it's really about practice
game day is going to take care of itself
i felt like we we did a good job i did a
good job of setting that standard and
obviously you see what those guys did
when i left you know they
wrote all the records and you know
that's after those guys they let georgia
to a national championship
uh didn't get it done but you know they
did did things beyond what i was able to
do so
can't be do nothing but be proud of
those guys you got chubb
number two in russian last year sony
super bowl champion so
you know it's just good to see the young
guys you know get their shine on
he's todd gurley of the atlanta falcons
joining us stan patrick show
you were in that gatorade commercial
with zion and bryce harper
did you get to hang out with those guys
no we all did it at our house so i did
it at my house in california
and then i guess bryce um did his maybe
in florida or or philly and then zion
did his in new orleans so it was like it
was like a
kind of like this meeting right here um
it was like a zoom shoot yeah no it's
good
it's it's it's good uh i was impressed
with that
do you how long does it take before you
move on past the super bowl loss
um i really try not to think about it
too much
trying to think about it too much
it's long gone you know i don't really
talk about it until like people ask me
so
it's still difficult to think about but
you know it kind of is what it is yeah
but it and then you go to a city like
atlanta where they don't want to talk
about their super bowl appearance either
but it's so funny you know we got a lot
in common um
it's just like i can relate to him
no other team i would want to be back
with or be with than the falcons so we
can get our payback
for sure how's your health how the knees
it's been good man i've been feeling
good
um the recovery time has been great so
you know obviously been on the same plan
that i've been on since
i came into the lead you know gonna have
a couple off days during camp or whatnot
but
i've been feeling good just kind of
taking it day by day
got a good um strength coach over here
uh
marty and his staff so it's been good
man i can't complain
you know just chucking away day by day
yeah you got i don't know if you have a
chip on your shoulder
but but if you do i certainly understand
it because it feels like you're only 26
i think
i mean it feels like people have moved
on from todd gurley
do you feel that um it's his part it's
just part of the nfl
especially with the running back
position it's kind of like
we just die overnight he's just like oh
he don't have it anymore you know that's
kind of one thing i feel like they
tend to do a lot with the running backs
but i don't know what i've done in this
league
i know everything i'm capable of
i don't really try to go out my way to
prove anything
to anyone i hear everything but at the
end of the day i know who i am
as a player um but more as a teammate
you know
when you start letting letting the
outside noise get to you and you start
bringing it to that locker room
you know your teammates or your coaches
are questionable then
and that makes it a lot bigger as long
as i can control what i control
uh just try to be positive every day and
just go out to practice and work
you know that's all i can do so it's
kind of like the norm for me now
you know i've been hearing it over over
the last couple of years
i don't really want to say chip but you
know it's definitely you know i just
want to go out there
everybody want to everybody want to go
paul
well i'm looking at these numbers the
five years first five years 70
total touchdowns you got 58 rushing 12
receiving
that's tied for fourth most in nfl
history by any player over his first
five seasons so ladainian tomlinson is
one
emmitt smith ii sean alexander who
played with the seahawks
then jerry rice you're you're tied with
jerry rice
for touchdowns over the first five years
of your nfl career that's pretty uh
pretty good company that you're in there
todd
yeah it's a blessing and i went down a
bunch of touchdowns too
so could could be could be top three but
like i said it's a blessing like i know
what i've done in this league
but it doesn't really matter this lead
is about
what you can do week in and week out
it's not about what you've done in the
past
or what you're going to do in the future
you have to be able to prove it that's
why you
you know you see guys like tom brady
who's been consistent for
years you know he's going on his 19th
year and you know
everyone's going to have a down year but
like
when you just set the standard so high
what i've what i've
been able to do you know these last five
years it's like
you know people expect more and i expect
more out of myself as well so
you know it comes with the territory you
just got to keep keep working hard
and now you get to see you get to see
brady twice
uh twice a year now yeah be careful what
you ask for there you get to
you know you know i just wanted to be a
great game but
i'm gonna yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be it's gonna be different but it's
gonna be fun i'm excited
it's a new new division for me um a lot
of new talent
i've been able to play against new
orleans basically every year since i
came in the lead
and you know played against tampa a
couple times against carolina
so i'm excited did you feel bad at all
for the saints
when that bad call in the superdome
no not at all
why would i ever feel bad i don't know
because you know that you guys got a
gift there
hey you can admit it now you're not with
the rams
hey the call was the call
it was a no call did you watch hard
knocks
at with the rams with coach mcveigh had
his shirt off did you see that
nah i was watching the chargers man my
boy
melvin ingram up i heard he got a new
song that dropped so i've seen
i've been just checking them guys out oh
so you watched the chargers part of hard
knocks you didn't watch the rams
[Laughter]
did mcveigh take his shirt off a lot
during practice
nah i ain't never seen that he acted up
he acted totally different now
for tv that's probably why did he look
big at least was he slow
uh yeah i guess he's yeah he's yoked up
a little bit
give him some credit he works hard
though he'd be working out
hey it's great to catch up with you and
uh have fun there in atlanta and thanks
for joining us we appreciate your time
todd
all right y'all be safe appreciate it
thank you it's todd gurley
the atlanta falcons running back joining
us with a phillies hat on